How's it going bros?
My name is Maaaaaaarkiplier
*laughs*
LWIAY intro song
Welcome to LWIAY
Last week you,
I,
Are...
LWIAY the show where you guys think you make fun of me
But I make fun of you because I get all the revenue
Damn it. Alright, let's see what kind of memes you guys posted this week.
haha
Ohhh I'm sure they're gonna be so nice. What do we got?
new meme, new meme, new meme, meme review
*laughs*
Stop saying that I kill memes
I make memes better
"Bonus meme gets hit on the far side of the screen"
*laughs*
the real reason there was no bonus meme
(reads) AH Yes the two genders
hoes and man
Ah
Yes, the intellectual
expression of the genders
speaking of Daisy from Star Wars that reminds me of the good old meme
[Daisy Ridley] That represents people of all genders
Two genders. All races and A...
(pewds laughs)
That's right
Your move Lip Tards
*Laughs*
I made a portrait painting of Pewds. I hope you like it
I know I'm supposed to be thankful and I'm know I'm supposed to be happy, but is my nose really that big?
Thank you very much.
Press F to pay respect. Keyboard cat
Ah, Keyboard cat. I thought it was just a puppet. This whole time. He had the hand up in the puppet.
And then that's how he played how is it possible? Oh my God did Bento actually play the keyboard what?
That's incredible
Bento! Ah, no Bento!
Universals picture source of income movies and own content Pewdiepie's videos, that's right
Basically for those who you don't know my last meme review video got
Demonetized by- oh it's back. That's right!
(He's a little happy)
*laughs*
MY revenune! MY money!
Good
Justice has been restored
When you're not invited to YouTube Rewind.
When you're not invited to HowToBasic face reveal. that's correct. I wasn't invited. that's it. yes
That's what happened. I am NOT, howtobasic
Upvote if you can hear this image, stop, we need to let this meme go you can have the chair meme
But this meme has to go, you go to YouTube gaming and it's literally all Fortnite
It's all Fortnite. It's all Fortnite. It's all Fortnite. Everyone is playing Fortnite
god damn it
I was banned from every gaming Royale game of all time because of this meme so let it go
When Marzia is in a PewDiePie video: a surprise to be sure but a welcome one
Man, the prequel memes have to be the best group of memes coming out of one source of entertainment
I feel like it deserves its own video
Probably will do it later this week
*Piano playing in video*
your mom gay
Why is the FBI meme still clinging about all the memes that I rate the lowest are the ones that keep going
Except the chair forget the handshakes awkward hugs is where it's at who took this?
Who took this, and why do you hug? It's like can I have a hug?
uuuuuuuh... Yeah... sure... here
There you go. Are you happy are you happy?
*reads comment* These clothes look exactly like my dealers. Thank you. Thank you so much
LWIAY HAS ARRIVED
*laughs*
oh, That's great, I'm gonna steal that right away
good meme good meme bravo
A picture of Pewdiepie made of pictures of Markiplier
Are they crying Markiplier ones?
I don't think sooo
Too bad. Try again next time
I want the crying PewDiePie out of crying Markipliers,  then I'll be impressed
Stop wasting my time
Will PewDiePie ever died?
Translated into Greek, and then translated Greek into English
The PewDiePie will never die
If there has ever been more solid evidence to show the fact that I have never died
Then let this be it
When you find me dead you will find me not dead, I'm Schrödinger's cat, you can't kill what is already dead.
Upvote so pewds can give answers. OK so basically what happened was I was
*bunch of reversed sentences*
(Repainting my gundam and then it got on my hand)
what is this? *shouts in agony*
Stop, stupid BIRD!
*laughs*
hmmmm
Which one should I pick as my wife? Too bad!
Natsuki is trash. I'm sorry Marzia. I'm going with Monika!
*pewds' signature anime voice* hell yeah man
New LWIAY video an accurate amount of people watching
BONUS meme
ohhh
You know I film the bonus meme every time no matter what just know that.think of all the lost memes
Let's have a moment of appreciation for that .
All the lost memes that will never see the light of day
Posted this last week got a ton of support but didn't make it to LWIAY people were saying
This should be Felix new avi for YouTube, so I'm posting it again. That's really cool
I would love to use it
But it looks way too professional for anything to be associated with me. okay?
Here on the Pewdiepie channel we're stuck with mediocresy
If it gets above that then you know something's up, okay?
You know something is wrong. So thank you, but no thank you
When you see how big his mousepad is
That's right
How do you think I got a girl like Marzia?
What the heck is this picture? It's absolutely terrifying. What's wrong with her eyes?
What's wrong with her eyes?
I'm scared. I'm scared of going home now. Am I dating a reptilian monster? Jesus
three means with no bonus memes - 2 memes with one bonus meme
What it's very different?
For the average view or maybe you haven't been on the channel long enough to really graph the idea behind the bonus meme
But it's a it's a very much different thing. That's right. *more reversed crap* (Help me speak please)
It's Felix, Sive
I wonder what's it going to say?
Give this shirt to Brad
Good meme good meme everybody you guys are creative sometimes of course not always
Upvote this so I can see the horror in pewds face
It's 369... THAT'S A GREAT PRICE
369!!!!!
And you can do 69 on it!
Look! It's super easy! You're welcome! We're dropping the price!
It's 369!
It's 369! It's 369!
THIS IS OUR JOINT
when you're a successful fashion designer
businesswoman and a huge youtube personality having
7.21 million subscribers, but everyone on r/PewDiePie submissions treats you like an innocent ten-year-old girl
A woke, Marzia meme seal of approval well done whoever did this. I couldn't agree more of course
And there it is!
Oh my God so cute, she just looks just like Natsuki if only they' switch the shirt and the skirt my god
So kawaii desu ne
Too bad Natsuki is the worst girl
I'm sorry Marzia you're despicable and this makes me like you even less. I love you. I'm sorry. I'm so sorry
I'm Fridays with Pewdiepie. Dr. Strange oh
Oh we're using made-up names
Then I am LWAIY
Alright yeah, this is Fridays with Pewdiepie by the way I forgot to tell you. How's it going bros?
Welcome to fridays with pewdiepie
It's definitely different from LWAIY
Complains about flexing on youtube meanwhile
Oh come on. I can't show off my ride? I was proud of that thing
It's got Korean wheels and a double clutch engine you can't hate on me for flexing a little bit
Come on guys. I loved when I did that video everyone gets so salty like everyone just went into defense mode
NO
No, I don't flex. What are you talking about?
Have I told you about my chair?
You guys are honestly the most
Awesome overwhelmingly supportive my favorite group of people
I am so lucky to have you okay, so it reads you mom gay. Haha so clever am I right
Never stop Pewds! optimism is great. Ah such a sweet post read the first letter of each line fam
Maybe you should read the first letter of mine.
No u
Absolute MADLAD
It's time to end LWAIY
YouTube's favourite show! Thank you guys for watching and supporting and posting the memes keep posting the memes in the subreddit
It's right there. Have a good laugh
And be immortalized on the Pewdiepie's subreddit
Think about it
Not too looong!
Since this is fridays with Pewdiepie
Guys, I love you so much
I do not have a twisted opinion about what some people on the Internet sees me as and
Just overly emphasize the fact that there's some sort of love connection going on here even though
I probably will never meet you, but I do love you very much
I love you guys so much. You're my soul. You're my entity.
You're my being.
if I ever meet you. I won't shake your hand, but I will awkwardly hug you
Food for thought
And as always
Brofist!
Pewdiepie with the six-oh win
Taking over YouTube
Tryna get like him
Brofist to the face
Can you keep up with the pace?
And i’m never gonna switch
BUT CAN YOU DO THIS!!??
How’s it going bros?
Gotta get it like this
When you wanna hit the flow
Grinding like open up pop a top and never stop
Run up in the city and i’m never gonna flop
Tell me when to go i’m like whenever
I’m done with this pass the mic to Edgar